I'm talking about like like there's
there's some someone [ __ ] show me
these new nicotine pouches they're not
it's not dip it's just like these white
tiny little pouches okay and you stick
them in your lip and it gives you a buzz
it's like supposed to be the jewel of
dip and then we have been [ __ ] white
claw you ever drink this [ __ ] no it's
everywhere now this hard seltzer water
what does hard cells or water it's like
Lacroix but it's like spiked and it's
like it's like the jewel of drinking cuz
it's like hundred calories per can oh my
queen italy hydrates you like all this
[ __ ] [ __ ] society do we live in no
I'm just thinking we're like what else
is there gonna be world what can we
invent that's like the jewel of jerking
off or something like that can hard look
the jewel of jerking off dude here you
go it's um a stimulant patch mm-hmm it's
got a small Korean based microchip in
there okay and you just stick it on the
line of your shaft huh and it you'll
just nut yeah yeah okay okay for like
two minutes
yeah yeah you just like slap it on and
it gives the sensation and you and then
you can stop chafing your skin you don't
have to touch it
yeah with yeah somehow it's clean like
somehow it's like it makes the jizz like
go back in or something nothing to clean
up yeah no there's like a little strip
that leads up to the base of your hole
mm-hmm and it's got like a lip on it so
and it catches it yeah or like yeah just
prevents drip yeah okay yeah I see that
I see that you slap that on with oh yeah
and then porn is gonna become more
meditative no yeah it'd be like those
jackoff instructionals but like it'll
just be like a calming voice mm-hmm
welcome to porn
No
welcome to release just gently applied
the strip to the base of your shaft and
make sure the lip is attached to the
bottom of your hole we will now begin
with some releasing sounds
[Laughter]
hardcore is fun that's like the that's
like the extreme strip then you get it
you listen to the audio track based on
the experience you want to have yeah
yeah
one could just be you know nice and just
mmm feel just stroking on your side she
is it's a it's a guy narrating yeah what
the woman is doing she's looking at you
she's seductively
she's tantalized by the experience
you're giving her with your beautiful
penis just what she loves it she moans
louder as you get into climax it has to
be poorly translated English she loves
you she loves your great cheeks what
could be the jewel of something I don't
know dude it's not much left hard look
or hard [ __ ] seltzer water yeah that
just sounds something like a plumber
would say mm-hmm genius no what do you
mean like that's something I would feel
like a plumber would tell me he'd be
like oh yeah you got a hard seltzer
water we got to change that yeah I see
that
so I don't know man what about some new
like opioid comes out it's like yeah you
love heroin there you go yeah it's way
better for you dude way way better yeah
the jewel of lien yeah yeah exactly
okay adderall is the jewel of meth yeah
yeah more or less clean fun version yeah
exactly has a clean fun hard drugs
hmm we could bring back peyote mm-hmm in
a nice way mm-hmm
that would be easy man Jules just double
up and like sell like the long like
opiate smoking thing like the old
Chinese yeah yeah giant pipes yeah but
it's like self-contained and it's about
six inches long that would be [ __ ]
fire see here we go smoke opium like
they you see but like way more moderate
aping opium it's just like it looks like
a pencil yeah this shit's great they can
bring anywhere
[Laughter]
[Music]
you've never smoked opium concentrate oh
my god
this changed my life wanna hit it he's
out for a whole day instant puke 180
tone [ __ ] it's clean it's easy it's so
much fun I hear this thing already
[Laughter]
[ __ ] dead oh my god
yeah you go Joule opium yeah what could
they name that pocket den oh yeah yeah
yeah den that's a good name yeah like
short name yet then yeah den stick on
you someone next to him bitching like oh
god this placing me so long it's gonna
be really short for me man
I got a den stick what's that doesn't
explain it cool oh do you just kill
himself what is this slow acting I don't
understand yeah den stick this looks
like a little iPod like it's like this
beautiful you know aluminum cool colors
like den sticks I send you it's the new
pocket opiate that everyone is you
and no one is talking about yeah that
sucks cuz it's gonna be a real thing
yeah and we're gonna we're gonna do it
yeah no yeah no no never
oh my god [ __ ] hell how's it going
dude take your vision notion right
that's not a flex